growing tensions between china and
australia were laid bare with this tweet
of a fake image depicting an australian
soldier
holding a knife to the throat of an
afghan child
alluding to a recent report on alleged
war crimes
by some australians what followed was a
war of words
with beijing refusing to apologize and
the stage-backed global times newspaper
doubling down with another cartoon of
australian soldiers
at the moment it appears that both sides
are not willing to stand back
and both sides are quite willing to
escalate
it's been escalating for years australia
has legislated over concern that china
was too involved in politics here
and it became the first country to ban
chinese tech giant huawei
from its 5g network it's also spoken out
about china's handling of hong kong
and the coronavirus beijing hit back
with bans and tariffs on australian
industries clearly
australia is taking economic punishment
for uh taking a political stance that
china does not agree with
now australia is taking beijing to the
world trade organization
threatening legal action over its
tariffs on bali
allies have rallied behind australia
with campaigns to buy australian
products
australian politicians have
traditionally taken a bipartisan
approach to china but in a rare divide
on foreign policy
the opposition labour party has accused
the prime minister of presiding
over a complete breakdown of
relationships
the government is now hoping for a reset
the question is how to reset relations
when china isn't answering calls
businesses caught up in the tensions are
hoping for a diplomatic resolution
in terms of immediate remedies or
fantasies there are none i don't think
but what we have been saying to
government is that we do need a reset
we do need to focus on you know working
through the challenges
the challenge will be navigating a path
between voicing what australia believes
to be legitimate concerns
while maintaining lucrative markets and
also
opening new ones nicola gage al jazeera
canberra